bonjour je m'appelle Boyer audre j'ai 27
ans et j'ai décidé de participer au
concours challenge et créateur dans la
catégorie Innovation alors on a décidé
de lancer une marque de prête à porter
masculin et féminin à la Réunion euh on
dessine en amont euh les modèles ensuite
on les fait fabriquer à l'étranger pour
les revendre ici à la Réunion donc en
terme de distribution euh la marque est
distribuée dans le Nord et dans le sud
de l'île ce qui nous permet d'augmenter
un petit peu la visibilité de la marque
et en terme de communication on est
présent sur tout les réseaux sociaux on
fabrique des tuniques pour femmes on
fabrique des tuniques pour femmes des
robes on fabrique des t-shirts des
sweites euh et également des casquettes
pour hommes donc voilà donc euh ce qui
fait l'originalité de la marque c'est
euh vraiment euh en terme de création en
terme de motif recherchés motifs
dessinés et son côté est puré j'ai un
bac + 5 marketing marketing étude de
marché commercialisation et j'étais
également demandant d'emploi donc et je
suis aussi passionné de mode donc j'ai
décidé d'allier on va dire compéten et
ben passion donc voilà donc on s'est
lancé dans une création d'entreprise
autour du prê àorter ça a pas été si
compliqué que ça puisqu'on a été
accompagné par la Chambre des Métiers et
la Boutique de Gestion donc on a eu
vraiment un excellent accompagnement
là-dessus et jusqu'à aujourd'hui il nous
suivent même un an après
l'immatriculation mais c'est vrai que
c'est un combat tous les jours et c'est
un véritable
défi